so I thought for Christmas I would gift
myself a new phone because this phone is
absolutely shattered how the [ __ ] did
you do that I was so I had it it fell
out my pocket while I was doing an IR
stream with this yeah and they've
smashed and now it is like pretty much
it's like usable 10 of the time took
some what kind of works but it's just
frustrating all right so I thought well
I got a new phone what'd you get how
hard can that be well let's let's hold
up on that before we get it okay just
tell me what's good I don't know so you
know originally I wanted like the maybe
the Z fold or whatever but I realized
that I can't mount it to my bike if I do
because there's no because it would be
like [ __ ] slapping around yeah and
they don't make bad flimsies well no
because like if you want a bike that
goes on your phone it's like because
it's just one like panel yeah you can
just have these like mounts that stick
to it really nicely yeah yeah yeah yeah
fold there's no mounts right now and I
was like well [ __ ] I'm throwing away for
the mount either right yeah no and so I
was like all right whatever I'll go for
the pixel so uh in Japan right I was
like you know what
I'm with um I'm with SoftBank I was like
okay well I'll just go to SoftBank
because I have a I have a so this phone
was a Sim free phone right so I bought
it from Google yeah and then I went to
SoftBank and I got a Sim free or sorry a
SoftBank uh SIM card yeah yeah yeah so I
thought I could just go to SoftBank
and get a new Google pixel 7 but oh no
of course oh of course no no no no no no
no no no no no you would like to make a
purchase so here's what happened right
here's how it all went without doing
paperwork yeah so yeah first of all you
can't even just turn up the phone store
in Japan you have to book it's a new
system they introduced for kovid and
they haven't removed it yeah so you
can't just rock up at a store and buy a
phone now you have to book yeah yeah
which sucks because it's like what if
with my phone breaks and I can't I don't
want to wait like two days yeah so
anyway I make this booking I say I want
to buy the new Google pixel uh Seven Pro
whatever
even though I already don't really like
this pixel but I'm like oh well I won't
be burned a third time right so so I go
to SoftBank and yeah again I just want
to buy a new phone I already have a SIM
with this provider yeah I just want a
new phone
and so
I go in and also right now they told me
I couldn't have tethering on my phone
because I didn't buy the phone from
softbanks I thought oh cool well okay
I'll buy it from then this time and I'll
get tethering so I go in I'm like can I
have the pixel and they were like uh no
I was like what do you mean I was like
I'll I'll buy it all in cash I'm not
trying to get like a like a loan on it
I'm just trying to buy the phone you
know like
[Music]
ah in this name it's like hard and
that's how you know like it's gonna be
tough and I'm like why that's the polite
Japanese way of saying [ __ ] off yeah I'm
like why why can't I not buy this and
they're like okay so right now even
though your sim is with us and you'd be
buying the phone with us it still
wouldn't turn tethering on because the
Sim we just don't want to allow
tethering on I'm like okay okay I'm like
fine I didn't really want it that much I
mean it would have been nice but I guess
like I'll just I'll just get I'll just
get a you know maybe I can this I was
like why are you being like it's not
like I wanted to tether anyway
actually I was like actually wait could
I could I actually get a new SIM card
that is for this new phone
and could I then have tethering and they
were like No And I was like what they
were like oh because your Visa is
expiring in a month
so we can't give you a new sim plan wow
and I was like oh but I already have a
plan with you they're like yeah yeah and
I was like and you're not going to
cancel that they're like no I'm like so
I can't so I can't get a new plan
yeah that is the exact same plan so they
won't let me start a new plan this
allows me to tether with my same number
and everything it's no different they
won't let me do it because my Visa is
about to expire I don't know I'm like
hey I'm renewing it yeah yeah on the
back yeah like no sorry like too many
foreigners have ran away so they changed
the rules and a lot of bad apple ruins
the whole world I'm like what the [ __ ]
I'm like all right fine I guess I don't
I don't need that at all all right fine
can I just get a new phone they're like
no I'm like
why can I not get a new phone and
they're like oh they're just trolling
yourself because if you buy this phone
it won't work with this Sim I'm like why
not I'm like wait so you're telling me
the SoftBank phone won't work with the
SoftBank Sim I have and he's like yeah
yeah it won't work I'm like wine he's
like oh cause you have a SIM free phone
right now and this this SoftBank Sim is
a Sim free SoftBank Sim and I'm like
okay and he's like so that that won't
work on our phone because our phone only
accept accepts SoftBank Sims and I'm
like I have a SoftBank Sim he's like no
no you so you have a free SoftBank Sim
I'm like what do you mean by that he's
like oh this only works on free phone
unlocked phones I'm like
so you're telling me the SoftBank Sim I
have won't work on your SoftBank phone
he's like no sir I'm like what are you
insane do you realize how stupid this is
they have to be trolling at that point
they just like we really don't want to
give this guy I'm like I'm like what do
you he's like yeah so if you buy a phone
right now it will not work with your
current Sim unless you get a sim that
can only work on this phone so I'm like
how does that make any [ __ ] sense so
are they trying to sell you a phone or
no they wouldn't sell me the phone at
all no because I had to have a A or a
plan only for their carrier but like did
they not give you like other options
being like but what you can do is they
were like get the [ __ ] out oh my God
they were like sorry nothing no can do
yeah
I mean you went through all that trouble
after a booking yeah and I'm like they
feel like I saw your Visa like illegal
immigrants obviously obviously you don't
deserve a phone I'm just like okay fine
[ __ ] me so my phone's broken I can't do
anything about it so now I I then I
afterwards I was like fine I'll go to
I'll go to like one of the other
carriers and I'll see what I can do yeah
yeah and they were like oh yeah because
your Visa is expiring well it's about to
expire on paper it looks like there's no
no carriers will let you join so
basically even though I already have two
more Sims with docomo for my streaming
bag they wouldn't give me one but they
did however docomo they did say they
were like hey once you if you buy an
unlocked phone from Google again and you
come back to us we can give you a Sim
the tethers hey talk about the goat yeah
I was like all right and they said best
of all because you have you already have
two sims with us if you have a third
with us we'll give you 10 discount all
the Sims and I was like oh music in my
ears so I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ]
cancel my softbanks in the moment I get
right I get I get my Visa right now
honestly I think it's out of spite I
think like locked phones are a [ __ ]
scam why why yeah why why are phones
locked to a network this is right and
this is why I've always bought unlocked
phones yeah I'm like I don't want to
deal with this this locked contract
[ __ ] yeah but Japan has designed a
system that will punish you for trying
to do that like that obviously you
obviously you can do it and some
providers do it but all the big
corporations and the big networks yeah
really don't want you to do it they do
everything in their power not make you
do it which is fine
if it wasn't hard enough already to get
a sim plan like it's it's hard like in
the UK you can you can order a Sim which
I did like uh for some of my friends I
ordered them Sims from the UK that they
shipped to Japan the company shipped it
to Japan ready so that when you come to
the UK it'll work and it's unlocked work
on any phone I think I think the issue
with a lot of these like Japanese
companies is the fact that their main
like Market base is just Japanese people
who are probably never going to use
another SIM like they're just like in
Japan the most they'll travel is like
[ __ ] naglia I mean I I say why would
they need why would you need wait so
you're gonna buy a phone but why would
you need another Sim you're not going
anywhere they've made a system so
stressful even compared to like the like
English contract and stuff like that
um that is so [ __ ] to deal with that
you'll just never question it and you'll
just keep yeah get upgrading your phone
you'll be like I don't want to deal with
having to do this [ __ ] again yeah it
just sucks it's just a simple like
solution right yeah yeah you don't want
to deal with it where it's just like
it's kind of all about brand loyalty at
that point which I feel like is
ingrained in a lot of them is the girl
man that's over your life
when I bought my other two sims they
were like no questions asked give this
man two SIM cards you know let's just do
it right now I do also find I find it
interesting how like going back to you
having a book an appointment at the
SoftBank because of like covered
restrictions
are we not beyond that point at this
point Japan isn't like Japan Japan is
still incredibly still so [ __ ]
paranoid